I'd like to present the next person to
show you his work it's Trent Matt
Kenickie
and it's rewiring the internet for
ownership big data and blockchains and I
also would like to thank our sponsors
that you can clearly see here and you
guys should remember that the panel is
coming in like two and a half hours
first we have this talk after this tuck
we change rooms if you want and yeah so
please welcome
Trent good morning everybody it's really
a pleasure to be here and I'm really
honored to be able to keynote this
conference I've been a big fan and user
of Python for a long time I think we're
shipping Python code in about 2003 or so
so in my previous company so today I'm
going to be talking about the internet
and big data and blockchains and some
other cool stuff lots of Python too
let's get going so if any of you guys
know me very well I really love robots
so it's maybe embarrassing to admit but
probably once a week or every couple of
weeks I go to a Google image search and
I type a search for robot and then look
at cool robots and why do I do this
sometimes just because it's cool new
things emerge you know you do different
searches furry robots mart-mart robots
Terminator robots whatever right there's
a lot of robot images out there and even
for this talk I actually was doing it
this morning so I really love robots but
there's a challenge you know if I want
to use an image of a robot and I want to
make sure that I have I'm using it in a
way that is fair to the Creator the
person who took that photo the person
who created that image how do I do that
so if I filter with Google Image Search
and say I'm only wanting to use the
robots images that are basically
reusable or reusable with modifications
and there's only a very small fraction
so in this first page there's only one
robot that I can use right the rest nope
you can't touch those robots or you can
I suppose if you want but you're not
giving fair retribution you're not going
to be fairly compensating that creator
and you're very likely not using a
legally
so that's really a problem and it turns
out that on the Internet 85% of images
found in Google search are actually used
in non legal way and most of this time
you know people use it just on their
homepage and it doesn't make a big
difference but there's a lot of times
where businesses use it and otherwise um
and it's really not very fair to the
creators so creators are kind of getting
a short shrift you guys remember the the
Sony rootkit issue of 2005 till 2007
so if you want to go and listen to an
album at that time let's say you really
loved Mariah Carey so you buy her Mariah
Carey album from 2005 well you you load
that CD into your computer and you start
playing it and immediately Sony
installed this rootkit which was an OS
level piece of software and it actually
basically opened up a giant backdoor for
all the hackers of the world and it
wasn't just you know 1 or 2 people's
machines that got infected there was a
total of 22 million CDs that were
shipped why did this happen well it was
basically because Sony was trying to
protect the the ownership that they had
that they had license from the artists
so and it wasn't just Mariah Carey it
was other musicians as well
our Lady peace a really awesome Canadian
band got affected there was dozens of
different bands that were affected and
in the end it really points to a
challenge and that challenge is about
DRM itself the idea of taking a file and
trying to lock it up really try is
defying the physics of bits because you
know at the very least there's an analog
hole right someone takes an image and
then they decrypt it to display it well
I take a photograph boom and I have it
right and so there's just all these
different challenges that where DM
really hasn't worked another great
example is DVDs and I don't know if you
guys remember Sony and this consortium
designed the DVD and they spent 20 or 30
million dollars in order to in order to
have proper encryption and all of this
DRM and then within two days or three
days of DVDs being released it was
cracked and Sony said oh my god it must
have been the NSA or some heavy-duty
high-powered organization that was
uncovered this and no it turns out
wasn't some high-powered organization it
wasn't the end of saying it was a kid
named John he's a teenager that's it so
this just kind of proves the point that
DRM is not only not very fair to
consumer it's not very useful for
consumers it's really bad for sort of
all involved and in an ironic twist of
fate at this rootkit thing that I
pointed just here to start with some of
the Sony rootkit code used some of the
code that John had used a hack of a beer
I'm initially from the DVDs so funny--i
irony there there's other problems out
there as well let's say that you want to
become a music company and you want to
help people discover music so there's
creators out there and then there's the
consumers the music lovers and you want
to connect them so your soundcloud or
Spotify or one of these companies well
in order to have a proper access to all
the artists of the world you know 90%
95% consumed you actually have to talk
to the music labels and depending how
you count it there's three or four of
these 800-pound gorillas out there and
you basically have to make a cut a deal
with them
to cut that deal they're gonna want to
take their 5 pounds of flesh so Spotify
a major portion of Spotify is owned by
the newzik labels SoundCloud doesn't
fully currently have all the licenses
and those music labels want their 5
bones of flesh so that's really a
challenge of course right so it's coming
too bad right because this means that if
you're a company that's really trying to
connect the lovers of music with the
creators of music you have to spend so
much time and energy in the legals of it
all rather than focusing on the user
experience rather than focusing on you
know helping the creators get
compensated or you know I'm an English
speaker I moved to Berlin in the last
couple of years and sadly to say my
German is not that great yet and so but
so I want to watch new release English
movies and so can I use iTunes no
because it sees where my IP address is
and it decides that it's going to
overdub in German for me can I use
Amazon no same problem can I use Netflix
yes but they don't have new release
movies and it turns out there's actually
no options for me except to use VPNs
which is sort of
a legal gray zone and this is what I get
all the time for things like this
YouTube you know friends send me links
and so on and there's just this
challenge of the the DRM there's sort of
a misalignment between what consumers
want and what's being offered and it's
basically really hard to access so I
wanted to create compensate the creators
I don't want to just you know download
movies for free I want to pain there's
no way for me to do it here's another
challenge out there in the world let's
say that I love our in fact I love art
myself and collecting digital art is
it's a pretty cool idea because you see
this you know image like this piece from
Jonathan Monahan called a skate plot
it's actually a video and you want to
buy it and how can you buy it in a way
where you truly own it so I buy the
piece for $1000 from Jonathan he would
probably give me a USB stick in the past
and then I want to go and resell it so
when I try and go and resell it to one
of you out there and say Don Don might
ask me hey Trent you know how do I know
that you own it how do I know you didn't
just download it from the Torrance and I
won't have a very good answer so that's
really a problem and in fact in the art
world
this is 664 billion-dollar market they
they the digital art part is called an
elephant in the room problem it's still
unsolved
or was soem solved 3d printing another
problem - so if you think about you know
Shapeways and Thingiverse these
companies out there it's really hard to
upload your work and then trust that it
won't be stolen so if you go to the
blogs of Shapeways you'll see quotes
like this my conclusion is that whatever
you put on the internet you lose it
maybe you keep the rights but you lose
the power over it so theoretically you
have the ownership practically you don't
and there's sort of a way to think about
all of this in the world there's sort of
two zones there's on the left the
copyright zone where you have this sort
of DRM lockdown castle it's restricted
difficult to reuse difficult to share
and on the right you have this sort of
public domain ocean it's unrestricted
use and there's a lot of good material
out there and it's growing but there's
also a lot of inferior and outdated
material and the challenges that a lot
of the material that you might want to
use is actually hidden behind these
castle walls
so to summarize
if you think about it ownership of
digital property especially on the
Internet is a mess it's a mess for all
of us involved for the creators it's
really hard to get compensated because
sharing means losing control and a lot
of people simply a lot of creators
artists 3d designers and so on simply
don't put their work up online because
they see that it will get taken and used
in ways they don't want for collectors
and audiences there's really no
secondary markets for things like the
jeweller and otherwise and forget the
connectors of the world you have to
you're often distracted by legals those
third party companies that want their 5
tonnes of flash and if you look at it
throw a rock and you'll find a problem
in any vertical almost from digital art
photography 3d music videos unless you
guys think that title is the whole
solution but anyway so really it's a
challenge across across out there and
you might summarize this challenge as
where's my stuff and to break that down
you can break it down to the wares and
my stuff part the wares means you don't
have visibility into what's going on so
you don't know that it's been shared you
know you put a piece of work out there
you don't know where it's been shared to
and what's going on and the my stuff
part means that the legals are really
painful if you want to sell a piece of
digital art right now quite often these
days you actually have to hire a lawyer
spend 1,000 or 5,000 euros he'll figure
out a contract for you and and then
you'll have it done and that's very
heavy I mean what if you only want to
sell a piece of digital art for 10 euros
or hundred euros you just spent most of
the money on your lawyer and so there's
this really painful legals you can
summarize that part as the user
experience for IP is broken so we can
ask this question why is it like this
why do we have this mess so so let's
take a look at some history of the World
Wide Web so we go back to 1980 1989 and
actually it was 1988 in May of 1988 Tim
berners-lee made a proposal to his
manager at CERN about this worldwide web
about this hypertext protocol that he
wanted to do and it was based on you
know there was lots of research going on
before
kids before but he made this proposal
his boss said hey that sounds kind of
cool go ahead go do this go ahead Tim
and a year and a half later within a
year and a half he had invented HTTP
HTML at the world's first web browser
all of these pieces that you need for
this overall system of a world wide web
and by almost any measure it's been
wildly successful so it it depending on
how you count it there's well billions
and billions possibly even a trillion
web pages out there now it's and it's
you know profoundly change society
itself now when we think about the
internet we usually think about the
world wide web and even when you think
about society a lot of is directly
related to the world wide web so this
piece of technology that was invented
very recently only 25 years ago has had
a profound impact but it actually has a
problem and I'm going to illustrate kind
of how
so let's say we create some art and put
it on the net so let's see I drew this
robot because you know I've always
wanted to be an artist but and no so I
create this robot and I it's obviously
great and let's say that I put it on the
web
well what can happen is other people can
take that save it and then put it on
their web page and they don't have to
even attribute me there's nothing that's
forcing them to attribute or anything
and they can copy and they can even sell
it on their sites and I wouldn't hear
about it I wouldn't know about it
there's also the unidirectional links
which the World Wide Web has so I could
take if I'm one of you out there I could
take Trent's image and I could put it on
my site and then link back to the
original site that's pretty cool
however I won't know about it because
it's only a unidirectional links so
which is actually kind of too bad - or
even worse and this happens all the time
as well misattribution right so someone
else claims that work and then a third
person attributes the person who is
copied that working claimed it as their
own
this happens all the time we deal with a
lot of digital artists and then like oh
my god I can't believe that you guys are
doing something about this because this
just happened to me last week in fact I
was talking with the digital artist just
yesterday where once again this happened
so there's a few pretty big problems
with the world wide web and you can
summarize it as in where is my stuff
challenge
there's no visibility because if someone
uses my stuff I don't know about it and
then my stuff once again the legal czar
painful
Jeff Atwood who most of you guys I'm
sure are well aware of he has this
really cool quote the current world wide
web does basically one thing simple
stupid mindless hyperlinks but that
alone to the credit of Tim berners-lee
and the world wide web that alone was
enough to build a functional unuseful
internet for the world so now the
question is then does it need to be this
way so if we look at the history of the
internet pre-world web web what's out
there so this go back to 1965 Ted Nelson
consider a unified service that would
provide storage and publication services
and manage royalty payment on a fair
basis that would facilitate unrestricted
virtually publishing sounds like a
pretty awesome vision right this is a
quote from 1965 it's called the Xanadu
Xanadu project the original hypertext
project in fact Ted Nelson actually
coined the term hypertext and what he
envisioned was the following a new
middle realm one which renders copyright
benign and flexible a winland system at
his bent as it is beneficial to both
rights holders on to users in a way that
other copyright systems are not
beneficial to users so on the left you
have this restricted copyright zone it's
always going to be there some people are
going to want to lock down things with
their heavy castles even though it DRM
doesn't work they're gonna still try and
on the far right you have the
unrestricted public domain zone ocean
and but in the middle you have this new
what what Ted Nelson calls he calls it a
trans publishing zone and it's anything
that can be quoted republished etc etc
without difficulty retaining the
copyright and retaining the copyright
benefits and so this is kind of a cool
idea basically fixing the UX for
copyright goes back to 1965 in fact that
was the one the paper was published it
was even earlier that Ted Nelson started
talking about this
so the Xanadu design looks like the
following
with my from my original image whenever
someone uses it there's actually links
both ways bi-directional links so and
it's built into the system
so and the second thing is that it
actually has baked in copyright and
inner and to solve this overall problem
known on the wares part you get the
visibility into the usage of your work
simply from these bi-directional links
and the my stuff apart the legals it
actually addresses it and via baked in
copyright so really an amazing vision
and ted nelson actually spent years
working on this here's a mock-up from
1972 showing these bi-directional links
and in fact he continues to this day to
be working on it he's going to be
releasing some stuff in the next few
months some videos explaining it all I
was having some correspondence with him
so but it actually turns out that the
Xanadu design was to put a mildly a
little more complicated than that so
here's the design from 1968 you've got
this meta structure level and this
construct level it's actually pretty
complicated to think about transclusion
x' all of this sort of stuff and it
turns out that this was in practice very
hard to implement so what happened was
it was so complex it was so hard to
build to do a really good job on that
it's considered the longest-running case
of vaporware ever even more than Duke
Nukem Forever actually which is quite a
feat right and one second even more than
Duke Nukem Forever and then along came
the simpler world wide web that Tim
berners-lee released in Christmas of
1990 and basically ate its lunch so
during the 80s and early 90s Ted Nelson
continuing on these efforts he started a
company on this that company had been
bought by autocad autodesk the autocad
guys and they were actually building
this building this building this and
within a couple of years of the web
being released autodesk shut that effort
down and it kind of made sense right I
mean there was a clear winner here and
in the end
Xanadu got largely abandoned so now we
have the World Wide Web
warts-and-all and Ted Nelson has this
just really awesome quote HTML is
precisely what we are trying to prevent
ever breaking links no rights management
and it's like exactly true so to
summarize so far what we've got is
ownership of digital property
especially on the internet is a mess
despite being anticipated since the 60s
and designed for but of course the seams
this happens often in software the
simplicity that one out in this case the
simplicity of the World Wide Web but
what that meant is that the question of
where's my stuff
one month of so a question we've been
asking ourselves is can we retrofit the
internet for ownership can we realize
some of the aims of Xanadu in the
process not necessarily the design of
Xanadu but at least the aims and that's
the question I've been asking myself in
my colleagues so here's the idea have
the bi-directional links but don't force
them into the design initially just to
autodiscover them and the second part is
make the legals secure and easy so to
summarize this is how the worst my stuff
part gets answered once again Auto
bidirectional links and easy secure
illegals now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to expand on each of these and
then I'm going to show you how we do it
in Python so on the where's part this is
actually well we we swallow the web okay
so we crawl the entire Internet and if
you restrict the the web pages the World
Wide Web to files that are 1 megabyte in
size you end up with 220 terabytes of
text ok a subset of those are links to
images and other media but let's focus
on images then when you can do is a
similarity match against the creator's
content so there's 13 billion images
there's a bunch of 3d designs all this
sort of stuff and if you think about
this this is a machine learning problem
at internet scale right and so this is
how we do it
and what this does is to know when
someone is using your work right and the
cool thing is these days this is
actually you know there's a lot of great
big data tools to do that
you run this with AWS you have different
libraries to do different things and you
can do this quite straightforwardly in
terms of code it's actually a relatively
small amount of code
well deployed the challenge actually is
to wrangle the big data itself right
because it's a lot of text a lot of text
and images to write because from this
220 no rights of
text you get 13 billion images how do
you handle that right and actually
interestingly one of the reasons we
weren't scared of this is in my previous
work where I was using machine learning
to design computer chips it's CAD
software for that we were routinely
handling 100 million data points or even
a trillion so 100 million data points
down to 13 billion it's like easy-peasy
one-tenth the size right so that's sort
of why we sort of realized we could go
for this without it being terribly
daunting now on the my stuff side to
basically lock down the legals in a way
that is useful there's two parts there's
the the actual legals and then the
securing it in some sort of time
stamping fashion so in our Terms of
Service when you use a scribe and say I
agree to the Terms of Service it's kind
of a special Terms of Service when you
register your piece of work I don't give
a demo later you're actually saying I
claim that I have the copyright rights
to this and then also when you go to
transfer ownership from yourself to
someone who has bought one of your
limited Digital Editions um it's
actually transferring the copyright
rights to that person think of it like
licensing plus plus so in a sense it's
copyright in a box it's fixing the ux4
IP you don't have to hire a lawyer and
spend a thousand euros or five thousand
euros to sort this out it's just under
the hood it's there and in fact we have
a lawyer on staff who has spent the last
ten years living in breathing copyright
and he really cares about this so in
fact his his last gig he cares about
privacy too so his previous gig he did a
class-action lawsuit on behalf of all of
Canada against Facebook for screwing
with users privacy anyone by the way so
we're very very happy to have him and
the reason is we're really leveraging
this towards making IP accessible to all
now the second thing is securing the
copyright so once we say ok when you use
this the magic happens in the Terms of
Service on this copyright transfer but
we want to make sure that you don't have
to just trust describe you know what if
something happens to us we go away want
anything like that imagine if it could
be stored on this this ledger that is
owned by no-one or owned by everyone
that's sort of out there it's like
itching in a stone if you record on it
and that of course is the Bitcoin
blockchain right so
at the very first use case of the the
Bitcoin blockchain is Bitcoin itself and
it's basically the world's first
practical solution to electronic money
in a way that people sufficiently trust
we're using it as well not to transfer
tokens but simply as a time stamping
mechanism and in fact Bitcoin in itself
it was actually a combination of two
things it's combination of work on time
stamping that goes back ten years prior
to that and hashcash which is basically
proof of work tied with money in a sense
so that's what bitcoin did was actually
tied together this concept of a
blockchain from previous work as well as
the the the money side for
incentivization so we're actually using
the blockchain and every time one of
these transactions happen every single
register everything every single
transfer Lolan kansai on all of this
stuff we're actually recording that
transaction onto the blockchain itself
and we actually created a blockchain
overlay as a protocol called spool Sapir
secure public online of ownership led
room and then the timestamp is basically
evidence that this happened in case
there's ever an ownership dispute and we
actually have been worrying you know
what if the blockchain isn't used in a
court of law as evidence well it turns
out that thanks to the Silk Road trials
the blockchain actually was use it as
evidence there and to the jury was like
no problem if it works it's fine and so
philic Road was actually very useful to
us and if you think about it it kind of
makes sense right because hard drives
have you been used in court for decades
as evidence and they can be tampered
with much more easily than the
blockchain so the blockchain is sort of
like this much more tamper resistant
hard drive in a sense so to give you a
feel of the Terms of Service we have
this you know fairly long terms of
service here's a snippet from it and we
keep updating this and improving it as
we go along as well the ownership
protocol the spool is basically
supporting all these different actions
and they are you know the core ones are
to transfer and to register so register
as an I claim that I have the copyrights
and to transfer as in I bequeath some of
these copyrights to the new owner and
I'm going to zoom into each of these
shortly here so overall this is what the
text acts like for ascribe on the very
top we have there
sort of two ways to use it there's
marketplaces and other institutions
organizations etc and then there is our
own web app at ascribe that IO and both
of those use our REST API which is you
know a standard restful api all that and
by the way the marketplace is then I
guess I'll get into this but this means
that anyone else can use this service to
anyone building their own service on top
in fact even already there's a couple
companies that are starting there
they've actually started to build on top
of ascribe digital art marketplaces and
there's several other people who are
using us as well who are established
companies so there's the REST API and
then below that of course is the our
servers for ownership and below that
basically it's basically the technology
needed to support these two main
features Auto discovering the
bi-directional links and easy secure
legals so to auto discover the
bi-directional links this is crawling
the web mixed with the internet scale
machine learning and then that's
actually you know the database that
we're crawling that we're looking at is
the internet itself right and on the
easy secure legal side there's really
two parts there's the Terms of Service
which of course is you know not very
much from a code perspective but it
really matters overall so it's a major
pillar and the second thing is the
blockchain side so on the blockchain
side there is at the very lowest level
the Bitcoin blockchain itself this this
very special database right think of it
like a blue ocean database where it was
it was it's basically a database but it
has a couple new features that are
really special right no one owns it once
you write to it you can never delete
from it and it's kind of not as good at
a lot of the traditional measures of
value of a database like it doesn't have
that high throughput it doesn't store
that much you know it's only 30
gigabytes but people talk about
blockchain but bloat but that's okay
because for how we use it it's perfectly
fine and on top of the blockchain the
API to the blockchain is the Bitcoin
protocol on top of that is our overlay
called the spool protocol so it's a
special dialect of the Bitcoin protocol
just for ownership and then on top of
that is something called PI spool and
transactions and these are two Bitcoin
libraries that we have written in a
scribe to implement the spool protocol
we actually just open-sourced them in
the last couple weeks so I'll be zooming
into those as well and basically the
ownership servers use all of this stuff
to implement ownership so I'm going to
talk about the different interfaces then
I'm going to start at the very bottom
and work our way up to the very top so
in the very bottom is the the spool
protocol itself and basically this is
how do you construct Bitcoin
transactions in order to timestamp these
ownership actions and you know typically
this is for if you're an adventurous
Bitcoin hacker and you don't want to use
some of the higher-level stuff you can
go for this and I'm going to talk a bit
about how this works and what are the
emergent properties so there's two main
transactions there's register and
transfer so the register is the
following in any given Bitcoin
transaction there is an input or
multiple inputs and then there's outputs
so in this case the input is the ascribe
address and we publish those addresses
and then on the outputs let's say that
you have three additions so you have
three it's like three prints of
photography but in this case it's
digital and so we have the following
outputs we have a hash of the work which
is well it's simply that you know this
and it's a Bitcoin address remember so
it's 30 characters long and it's the
hash and then we have one Bitcoin
address for each addition we have an
opera term for register and this is sort
of like a way to attach verbs to Bitcoin
transactions so that's how we use it and
finally there's change so the way that
Bitcoin works even if this transaction
only caught I want to send over say 25
cents but I have $100 in my wallet I
have to send over the hundred dollars
and then I get back 99 dollars and 75
cents that's just how Bitcoin works so
it's a quirk of Bitcoin but that's okay
so that's why we need to change so this
is to register and once you've
registered it's basically time stamping
where you're declaring I claim that I
own this and that I have the copyrights
to this piece of work now the second
transaction is transferring ownership so
it's actually very straightforward you
have a previous address that owns the
piece
so it would be one of these here one of
these for example in the first one and
then it leads to simply a new address
for the new owner so every time a new
person wants to buy an addition well we
automatically generate an address for
them and basically the funds flow from
the old to the new we never ever by the
way as an aside we never ever store
passwords or private keys or any of that
so we don't need to you don't have to so
of course we don't and of besides that
there's two other things that are
necessary once again the Opera turn
which is the verb in this case transfer
and then change and basically the the to
summarize the protocol you can say the
first time that any Bitcoin leaves the
existing owners wallet ownership is
transferred to this new wallet or
address now this a really cool thing
that happens is provenance the chain of
ownership history emerges naturally so
you're it's going from owner one to own
or two to own or three to owner four and
you can go onto the blockchain and
easily see this very straightforward
thing and this is actually critical in
some fields so in the world of art
provenance is everything actually if you
have a painting that looks like it's
five hundred years old but you don't
know where was four hundred years you
don't know whether it's that da Vinci
that long-lost da Vinci but actually you
can recover a provenance sometime if you
do the right forensics and so on in this
case before the this blocking based
approach there was zero provenance for
digital so once again the example were I
had bought a piece of art from Jonathan
for a thousand euros and then I tried
selling to to someone out there they say
how do I know that you own it well now I
have an answer I own it because the
previous person owned it and the
previous person owned and that was
attached to the artist so now you
instead of no provenance you have
perfect provenance and another thing
that's kind of cool is every single
piece of work gets a unique ID so in
this case how we do it is we just say
they're the Bitcoin address of the
original owner right here that's the
idea of the piece so it's like a serial
number or a vehicle identification
number and then you can actually use
that and I'm not sure if you guys saw
but my very first slide I actually
ascribed this these slides so this slide
deck actually has an ascribed address
and I've claimed copyright rights so so
that's that's that
and in the register transaction what's
cool is it's actually binding when you
when you say ownership what it is is a
binding between a creator and a piece of
work a piece of art and by having these
in the same transaction the hash which
is a fingerprint of the piece and the
addition of the owner then it's the
clearing that it's kind of binding these
together for all eternity
so basically that's the spool of
protocol and it's implemented at the
same way that we have it running on on
the Bitcoin blockchain now one level
above that interface to working up a
stack is in order to implement this
we're using Python and the protocol
sorry we're using something called PI
school which we actually just
open-source last week and basically in
four lines of Python code you can
register ownership on the blockchain and
then you have to have your wallet set up
and stuff like that but in general it's
very very simple
and we've gone way over way to document
this so if you go to github.com slash
subscribe you'll you'll see all this
stuff by the way and under the hood we
actually had been using three other
Python libraries out there for various
aspects of Bitcoin transactions pi
Bitcoin tools and a couple other ones
for HD wallets and so on we only used
you know one or two commands from each
of those libraries and we had a lot of
dependencies so we decided you know what
let's make a super simple library to
support simple transactions pushing
transactions to under the block chain
including sort of the colored
transactions and so we actually created
this library called transactions and
it's dead simple as well and I'll zoom
into both of these but overall what the
interface is about here is making it
really easy for others to use this
protocol and it's a reference
implementation so let's do them into PI
school so you import the library you
declare the spool object the thing you
need to do first is you need to refill
your wallet just so that you have some
money to spend because every transaction
costs money for us we actually swallow
and ascribe so if you're using the
service it's free for anyone using the
web app it
three cents and overall how do we pay
for that it's actually the the business
customers at scale who are using our API
at scale so it's a freemium model and it
works fine but what that means is people
using the web app never ever ever need
to think about Bitcoin or buy a Bitcoin
however if you're using high school you
need to have you know that because
there's not a way to to pay there so
once you've have enough funds in the
wallet then you just do a call called
register and you pass in these different
arguments that I had pointed up before
in the protocol and that's it it doesn't
and then once you've registered you can
basically specify additions in different
ways and let's see here and then you can
transfer ownership as well so basically
spool that transfer you pass in the the
previous user and the new user all of
this stuff and it just happens so it's
very simple on purpose and the other
library which is transactions library is
also very simple on purpose so you
import transactions you create a
transactions object you can create a
simple transaction then you sign it and
this is very important if you don't sign
a transaction to sign a transaction is
declaring that you have the password for
that transaction the private key because
otherwise if you're pointing to an
address you have to be able to send
money from its MMO right it's part of
the idea of Bitcoin and then you
basically push this to the network right
and basically that's you know putting it
out on to the thousands of Bitcoin nodes
that are out there to verify and it's as
simple as that actually all right so
that was the the lower-level interfaces
the the spool protocol itself and then
the Python implementation of the school
protocol and this third interface is the
REST API so in this case it is well like
exactly like you would expect it's it's
a REST API and you pass in things like
the the user email the file URL this
sort of thing and then it simply returns
success all of that and this is also all
documented on github comm slash describe
and where this is used actually is if
you are running a marketplace and you
want to sell digital goods right because
you know before now let's say if you
want to sell shoes online right it's
pretty clear you deliver the shoes the
person who bought the shoes gets the
shoes right but if you're selling you
know photographs or if you're selling
digital art or any of this what is it
that specifies that that new owner is
the person that paid for is actually
truly the owner right and if you're
certain traditionally you would have had
to you know once again pay a lawyer five
grand or ten grand to sort this out now
it just comes out of the blocks so a way
to think about this is just like PayPal
and stripe kind of made payment
processing easy you just plug into them
and then you've got it handled you don't
need to worry about PCI compliance and
all that stripe takes care of it in our
case we're doing ownership processing so
you don't have to worry about all the
legals related to ownership and
copyright escribe just takes care of it
so it's its ownership processing and
finally on the very top is the the web
app and this is really for targeting the
individual creators artists graphic
designers photographers writers whoever
wants to register can sign their work
and of course it works for individual
galleries for collectors any of that and
you can just go on and sign up it takes
you a minute in fact I'll give a quick
demo later so overall you know going
back to this problem that I talked about
on the internet about ownership for
creators collectors and connectors so
now there's actually a way for creators
to claim and protect ownership and by
the way it's on the side kind of the way
that copyright law works is as soon as
you write something down as soon as you
create something you actually have the
rights to that but how do you prove that
to the world that's the big challenge
right and that's what this is about to
sort of have this very convenient way to
prove to the world that you own it in a
sense you know if you wanted you can
take that I put it onto a USB stick mail
it to yourself and keep that envelope
sealed right that's one way and people
do this we've met many artists to do
this so think of what we're doing here
is a really convenient boost office to
mail stuff okay and of course now you
get to share without losing control so
things can kind of go out there and you
don't have to worry anymore
and finally we actually have a
certificate of authenticity and it turns
out and it's cryptographic by the way it
turns out that a lot of collectors in
the art world and otherwise one
have this sort of piece of paper at
least PDF document that says hey you
know I'm the owner and it looks kind of
official and all that so we do that and
we make a cryptographic and in our case
that means we have signed it in the
crypto sense using the ascribe private
keys for collectors now basically it's
really simple it's enabling secondary
markets it's so I can resell my my
digital work I can resell my photograph
all of that and then connectors right if
you're going to be starting a startup
now to sell digital art or or music or
any of this it's going to be a lot
easier than before so much less risk of
a legal mess simply because we've taken
care of that and this works across a
whole variety of verticals digital art
3d photography and so on in a scribe
we've actually a lot of our marketing is
focusing on digital art simply because
it's a really big pain point but it is a
general thing so quick demo so once
again here's another great work of art I
love Bitcoin and Microsoft Paint which
is actually yeah there you go
sorry it's not Kim sorry guys and I go
to the landing page of a scribe ascribe
that I oh I click sign up I fill in my
user my email and a password that's it I
click on agreeing to the terms of
service because that's this magical
Terms of Service right and and then I go
in and I now I have a place to drop my
artwork and then I have to enter my name
the title the year created and the
number of additions so I enter all that
I upload the file I chose three editions
so this is cool right once again unique
digital editions I click register and
what does it do it actually takes all
this stuff hashes the piece and it puts
it to the blockchain as well as storing
it on the ascribe servers and that
actually is convenient to a lot of
artists to manage their collection they
it's sometimes it's like cats right so
if it's all stored on the cloud in one
convenient wallet if you will or
portfolio then that's really nice so so
we do that and then you have the piece
detail so you've got your work you've
got your artist name and title and all
this and you've got this ascribe ID here
so this is actually a Bitcoin address at
a serial number if you will and what you
can do with it
like transferring consigning consigning
means letting someone else sell on your
behalf so we have that built in as well
and then you know all the other details
including the spool details which is
related to the Bitcoin stuff I'll show
that so overall then let's say I
register three works this is your
archive of work your portfolio your
wallet right and so that's what I have
and I can I can transfer stuff so I just
click on the transfer button back here
on the top right the transfer button and
I type in an email of someone I want to
transfer to and now that person gets the
IP rights to that work so it's as simple
as that you can basically email to
transfer IP it's no more calling lawyers
no more filling at all this contract
stuff it's fixing the ux writing and you
know it's a cool thing this app is using
bitcoin but you don't have to know
Bitcoin at all but if you want you can
cross check so on the bottom of this
there's the spool details and it gives
the ID and it actually gives links to
blocking out info as well as the raw
transactions and it points to the hashes
and the other stuff too
so if you click on that first link there
it takes you to blockchain to info and
you can see that this is going on on
blockchain and info is one of the
probably dozen services out there that
are blocking explorers so they're just a
way that you know they look at the
blockchain and then they make it
publicly available and searchable and
browsable in an easy fashion so it's a
third-party service or you can go to
colored coins
sorry coin secrets org which is focusing
on colored coins for example so ascribed
over all this work from jonathan
actually was sold at bit forms new york
city it's probably the world's leading
digital art gallery it's it's a physical
location in New York actually and it's
been around for about 20 years and so
Jonathan he actually had three editions
of this and this is actually Edition two
or three we've got the ID there and in
fact I think we have this piece in our
landing page as well so he actually did
a loan to us so we actually have the
copyrights be alone artists are have
used this actually for things like the
Berlin Art Prize so we worked with the
Berlin art prize folks
and in this case about 300 artists
ascribed 600 works as part of the
registration process to
apply to the Berlin Art Prize a couple
months ago now this we're pretty proud
of this one on Mac Vienna which is this
150 year old museum it's older than
Canada it actually bought ascribed
digital art for its collection and
they're very very happy with that right
so it's kind of cool right this
institution that's been around like
super super long is actually buying
visual art and they're very comfortable
with it because it's basically it
ascribed contemporary this is an example
of a gallery that is selling work online
in this case they're selling it with
bitcoins so every 10 days they sell a
different piece of work sometimes it's
digital sometimes it's physical but for
all the digital stuff they're they're
using the service of a scribe and
they're very happy with that they've
actually been waiting for a year a
couple years in order to do digital art
so when when we connected they were very
happy and we worked with him a lot
they're really great on our landing page
actually there's some other work that we
decided we wanted from this artist named
Ella Frost so we actually contacted her
and said hey we'd like to buy some
editions of your work and so we bought
them and she transferred them to us and
now we're using them on our landing page
and that one didn't work oh okay so here
also actually just yesterday we
announced that Creative Commons is using
us so if you go to Creative Commons Fr
it's the France to start with more to
come but France to start with if you go
there you scroll down you'll see you can
register with a scribe you click on that
button and it goes to a CC dot ascribe
that I owe so it's a Creative Commons
basically wallet or registering service
where you once again register your piece
you give the title all of that and then
you choose to light the Creative Commons
license so in this case it's actually
registering the work according to one of
the six Creative Commons licenses so
it's not just about ownership actually
it's about attribution so in this case
you're saying hey you know I'm going to
copy left this thing and I just want to
have you know the rights with whatever
license I choose so some of them are
about attribution and so on and it's
basically helping to secure that you own
that piece and we have lots of users for
different things digital artists
photographers creatives and marketplaces
too so we're worth quiet about that
right now but we're working with many
companies and galleries and museums and
so on
about ascribing work and basically
overall you know we've been coming along
but kind of where we're at right now and
the web path is out there the API is out
there the open source pie school and
transactions and the the track the part
where we crawl the Internet we're
actually just wrapping up the crawling
now so in June that's going to be
available via the REST API right now
it's available but in an alpha form
basically and it's going to be exposed
in the web app as well so think of it
like media analytics like Google
Analytics but to kind of see the the
propagation of your file and where it's
shared and all of that so overall we can
think of ownership of digital property
especially on the Internet is a mess
right
despite being anticipated since the 60s
and designed for write the world wide
web one out it was really you know much
simpler and it left this where's my
stuff question unsolved but we figured
out a way to answer this this question
of where's my stuff right and the worst
part is via Auto bi-directional links by
literally swallowing internet internet
scale machine learning on images and not
just images that we're actually already
doing it for 3d 3d designs as well and
as time goes on for text and for movies
and so on and then on the my stuff part
easy secure legals via Terms of Service
and our ninja lawyer and also the
Bitcoin blockchain
and this is the the spool protocol and
all of this is Python or actually well
the backend is Python right the front
end is a bunch of other stuff react and
some other things so overall this is
about and ownership layer of the
internet or even more generally the
attribution layer of the Internet and I
that's it actually so I hope you guys
found this interesting thank you very
much and I guess we'll open to questions
so questions yes go ahead
so if you want to pay for for a piece of
work with with bitcoins but the seller
and the buyer don't really trust each
other is there a way to make the
ascribing and the transfer of of
bitcoins an atomic operation other is
and in fact when we started out we were
doing that where we had human processing
built into the system but everyone kind
of has their own way of doing the buying
and selling and we found that we are
getting too close to being on
marketplace and we those are our
customers right so we actually removed
all of that so if you want this atomic
operation you would actually go through
whatever marketplace you're going
through right but from our perspective
we really want to focus on the
attribution part and avoiding how the
actual value transfer of the the the
money itself so that was actually a
conscious decision to not make an atomic
transaction yeah yeah yeah yeah
first of all thank you great talk
a few years ago I discovered a project
called expire which is basically a
message for ultra raising it [ __ ] and
like given images a timestamp like after
that time its expires so I was wondering
how are your thoughts on this topic like
I want to rent maybe the stuff for
exposition and after a period of time it
just expires and you don't have the
rights anymore and I wasn't this yeah
for sure by the way I can't see you
where are you raise your hand please oh
there we go Laurie hi great yeah so
actually that's alone and we support
that functionality it's the the main use
case we see is when a digital artist
loans to a museum for an exhibition so
there's a start date and an end date and
that's just how it works and in fact the
work from Jonathan Monaghan that we show
on our landing page he's actually loaned
that to us for a fixed period of time so
yeah we support that
Christiane's first yeah first of all
super cool very impressive making a
business out of odd Bitcoin and
copyright law it's very very cool I am I
wanted you have a way of dealing with
disputes so say you didn't like ascribe
your slides and I just found them online
somewhere and I upload them I'm assuming
you can't just rewrite the provenance on
the Bitcoin betcha
yeah correct so kind of how we view it
is when you're using the Bitcoin ledger
it is evidence that can be used in a
court of law in case there ever is an
ownership dispute and ultimately that's
the ultimate fallback right so the
different people who claim ownership end
up in front of a judge and jury of their
peers and they talk about it right
of course that's relatively heavy
friction in the legal process but even
just knowing that it would end up like
that with this extra proof helps a lot
so let's say that you don't own a piece
and you register it yourself
congratulations you've just committed
fraud and you've exited into the
blockchain that you're committing fraud
so good luck with that one in court
right so and but as time goes on we
actually see that we want to have
simpler arbitration processes and
whether we do that or third-party
services we will see we actually see
that a lot of marketplaces have their
own approaches to it already so for us
we're kind of learning about how this
should work and right now we're really
focusing on the authentication aspect
itself okay select two more questions
fantastic presentation thanks a lot this
is really exciting two questions and one
is if you think especially in particular
think about photographers a lot of their
work even though it's digitally made and
digitally available they still sell it
in a paper copy so question is do you
have you thought about expanding your
copyright and licensing works into the
physical world and the second the second
piece would be how do you we haven't
talked that much anymore about the
where is how do you follow up and how do
you police contracts yeah yeah so for
the first part physical do we do
physically etc in fact one of our
marketplace customers is selling
physical paintings and what we're doing
actually works for that as well
ultimately it is a book the copyright so
what is what are the media that
copyright applies to it can be physical
goods it can be digital on the second
part the the crawling the web and giving
the information that actually comes back
to right here so we actually have in
basically beta right now they're
crawling the Internet and offering it up
via the REST API but we haven't built
the front-end for it yet where you can
explore in the sort of media analytics
sense think of it like Google Analytics
but seeing where your stuff is that
what's coming so we're targeting some
time in June for that that part is going
to be we're targeting to make it free
for all the users of the web app so it's
just you know you go to the page the web
page where you have your art registered
and so on and you click a different
button and you can see where it's
showing up and how many shares there
have been and these sorts of things the
enforcement we leave up to the users yes
and although as time goes on you know
like you have different actions once you
discover that someone is using your work
there's a few different actions right
one of them is just let it go right and
that's usually what you should be doing
and maybe you should be happy because
you know if you have a piece of digital
err and there's a million shares that's
a really great proxy for value right in
fact there's some digital artists they
say my art is going to be sold as ten
times the number of YouTube views right
so and that's actually kind of cool
right there's one artist we deal with he
he took that idea and he did it for
Pinterest pins and then he went and
people are like oh that's cool that's
cool and they're liking his Pinterest
stuff and then he went and bought 5,000
Pinterest followers just to kind of hack
the system even further right but going
back to your question what are the when
people find out what are their recourses
right so there is let go knowing that
there's a proxy for value and then
there's different monetization models
right there's there's tipping which we
think is really cool and
one of the artists that were working
with actually said please change hit me
with the Bitcoin network with changetip
and he was giving away pieces based on
that there's basically emailing them and
saying hey you know I see that you're
using this I'd like it if you to you
know either take it down please or just
license it from me for 10 bucks or 50
bucks right or you can just send a
takedown and to me I like take down to
the bane of the universe it's sort of
exactly the opposite of how the world
should be right part of the reason that
takedowns are so prevalent right now is
that it's really hard to license work
that isn't part of some stock
photography library right like if I do a
Google image search I see all these
images it really should be easy to know
which how to basically license that work
from each of those owners so we will
build building functionality like this
to sort of bias towards you know people
who want to fairly compensate the
creators and bias away from you know
outmoded ideas of thinking like
takedowns which are exactly backwards
right yeah yeah the owners have title
right so and if people want to use it
that's great and ultimately like when
you're buying this stuff you know that
it's going to get out there and so on
right so if you if you don't want to buy
it then you don't buy it
if you know it's going to be sure to a
million people or whatever so if and if
you're not comfortable with that then
don't buy the piece yeah yeah I don't
fully understand what you mean but
basically like all of this comes down to
transfer of copyright rights right so
this is the difference between access
and title right so anyone can have a
copy and all that it's no problem no
problem right there's peer use all of
this right but who has title right and
what does title give you title gives you
the ability to resell it gives you the
ability to loan for like exhibitions and
all this to display publicly all of this
right basically the types of rights that
come with having the copyrights yeah
um thanks for the talk was very
interesting um I'm curious about have
you come across the like data use case
right so one problem that you have like
if you're a researcher is how do you
other on UCI datasets right for machine
learning purposes
how else do you get stuff what I'd like
scraping or borrowing or stuff you know
the number of people who use stuff
probably what I ferry so I was wondering
if that use case come across we've seen
a bit of that of course like I mean
there's a whole bunch of challenges with
sort of the curation of datasets and
right now we're inaudible curation right
that's sort of people at one level above
but if you are a curator of datasets
whether you're an archive who we do with
a lot well an archive of images or of
art or whatever or datasets for UCI or
whatever you would use our service to
register to till alone and all that but
we're not trying to solve the problem of
curation itself right that's we leave
that to other people to to address one
final thing to and that is we're hiring
so if you guys are interested in us then
we actually have back-end and front-end
and UF ja UX jobs available so so thank
you give a big round of applause
you